and her brother ron in the middle of
berlin
their flight from the philippines to the
german capital took 12 hours
this is the first time here for both of
them
finally
i've made it
berlin's a big city and it's a beautiful
city i can't believe i'm finally here
then
saya has been learning german for three
years at home she studies european
languages she's especially interested in
german history and culture
their first stop is the berlin cathedral
i'm really looking forward to seeing the
berlin cathedral
at home we have a lot of cathedrals too
and i want to see if they're similar
the berlin cathedral draws lots of
tourists its history goes back to the
15th century since then it has been
altered again and again partially
destroyed and rebuilt
with a total height of 116 meters it is
berlin's tallest house of worship but
not as big as seya had hoped
i thought everything would be a lot
bigger but it's certainly very very
pretty
the east side gallery at the former
berlin wall is saya's second destination
after completing her studies the 25 year
old wants to go into the tourism
industry and gain experience working
abroad
she'd even like to live in berlin even
the weather doesn't bother her
i think germany is great because the
people are really friendly and it's not
stressful
the weather is always good it doesn't
rain oh and
yeah i thought we couldn't in here we're
learning about the place's history too
i'm interested in history
third stop brandenburg gate saya has
seen it in many photos
now she can touch it and even walk
through this landmark whose ties to the
history of german reunification are
unparalleled
standing here in front of the
brandenburg gate this is really
meaningful for me
in the past the brandenburg gates
symbolized the division of germany today
it's a symbol of freedom and hope that's
why it's
important is
wants to take a special photo here to
take home as a memento a reenactment of
the picture that won the euromax contest
for her
the high point of the tour a visit to
the new euromag studio just around the
corner
euromax host christina stutz personally
welcomes the brother and sister and
gives them a glimpse of what goes on
behind the scenes at euromax
since the middle of june euromax has
been broadcasting from its new studio at
parisa platz
today taya and ron experience what goes
into a euromax production and not just
the finished show the 25 year old
contest winner has a chance to play
presenter herself
i hope you had fun and that you learned
a lot in the studio
i didn't expect the studio to be so big
i'd only seen it on tv
but now i've seen it up close
and the presenter was really nice
a day roaming around berlin can
certainly make you hungry saya and ron
refuel with one of the city's
specialities they get their first taste
of berlin curry sausage
they're good
their last item is the festival of
lights for 10 nights this month light
artists are illuminating more than 70
buildings for tsar and ron the day ends
at the concert house on jean-darmanmarkt
gonzaga i can tell you that i really had
a perfect day
i saw so many wonderful sights and met a
lot of great people
i'll take home the really great
experiences i had here in berlin
now return to their home city of bola
khan in the philippines with a suitcase
full of berlin impressions and memories